faire commun dans une entreprise c'est
effectivement travailler en commun pour
arriver à faire en sorte que les
activités de cette entreprise puisse
être une manière générale h 30 repas par
des clients plus que par des
consommateurs
aujourd'hui on va beaucoup plus vers une
logique dans les entreprises où on est
au service du client et on va voir petit
à petit sans doute s'intégrer petit à
petit les les les clients en définitive
au sein même de l'entreprise alors
évidemment il ya les points contraire
avec 17 équipes là qui permet également
de voir exactement le contraire de ce
que je suis en train de dire mais moi je
ne fais pas partie de ceux qui vont voir
d'une manière négative d'une manière
systématique pour justifier tel ou tel
aspect qui soit positif ou négatif
le télétravail c'est quelque chose
d'excessivement sérieux en définitive
c'est politiquement sérieux à partir du
moment où on a confiance envers les
hommes
on doit avoir honte de la pouvoir mettre
en place des travail parce que c'est un
c'est d'abord comme je les dis dès le
démarrage
c'est d'abord un acte de confiance
réciproque entre les uns et les autres
à
[Musique]